hallo guten Abend schön dass ihr dabei
seid willkommen zu ZDF heute live die
Welt hat am Wochenende nach Russland
geschaut auf den Aufstand der
wagnergruppe der dann nach einigen
Stunden schon wieder vorbei war aber
trotzdem stellen sich ja nach wie vor
einige fragen wer wusste was was macht
Jeff brigoschin jetzt in Belarus und wie
wirkt sich das alles auf dem
Kriegsverlauf in der Ukraine aus und
nicht zuletzt war das jetzt der Anfang
vom Ende Vladimir Putins darüber wollen
wir heute sprechen mit Severin Kleier
vom Bundeswehr think tankt die ideas er
beschäftigt sich unter anderem intensiv
mit der wagnergruppe wir wollen reden
mit meinem Kollegen daran Hassan Sade er
ist aktuell in der Ukraine in saporisia
und mit Andre soldatov er ist ein
russischer geheimdienst-experte und
investigativ Journalist schickt uns
gerne eure Fragen eure Kommentare die
postet er am besten ganz einfach in die
Chats oder ihr schickt uns eine mail
aber jetzt erstmal guten Abend andre
soldato
können Sie leider noch nicht hören das
wird sich hoffentlich gleich ändern ich
sage es kurz wir erreichen sie heute
Abend in London wir sprechen gleich
miteinander vorher bringt uns Sebastian
eben mal kurz eben auf den aktuellen
Stand der Dinge
mit Verzögerung ist die PR-Maschine des
Kreml voll angelaufen Wladimir Putin
meldete sich mehrmals bin in weniger
Stunden zu Wort bei einer
Gedenkveranstaltung spricht er vom
glorreichen Einsatz der
Sicherheitskräfte gegen die wagnergruppe
die er Verräter nennt
[Musik]
unsere Waffenbrüder die Piloten starben
bei der Konfrontation mit den Rebellen
sie haben nicht gezögert und haben ihre
Befehle und ihre militärische Pflicht
ehrenvoll erfüllt
putin will der Welt jetzt vor allem eins
zeigen er hatte auch während des
Aufstands alles unter Kontrolle der
Präsident gibt heute erstmals zu dass
die wagner-gruppe mit über 900 Millionen
Euro aus Staatsmitteln finanziert wurde
die finanzielle Unterstützung der
gesamten wagnergruppe hat vollständig
der Staat übernommen am Nachmittag ist
Wagner Chef Jewgeni prigogin in Minsk
angekommen das bestätigt der
belarussische Präsident Alexander
Lukaschenko der sich heute vor laufenden
Kameras für seine erfolgreiche
Vermittlung zwischen brigon und Putin
brüstet offen und selbstbewusst spricht
er darüber wie er den wagner-chef in
seinen Sicherheitsapparat einbinden
können
wenn die wagnerkommandeure zu uns kommen
und uns helfen ist das eine gute
Erfahrung sie kämpfen an vorderster
Front das sind Sturmtruppen sie werden
und sagen was im Moment wichtig ist
unklar was er damit meint doch Putin
dürften diese Worte nicht gefallen
Lukaschenko will eng mit einem Mann
zusammenarbeiten den Putin öffentlich
zum verräte erklärt hatte
der Chef der wagnergruppe privatin hat
ja gestern erklärt dass er die Regierung
gar nicht stürzen wollte er wollte
seinen Vertrag neu verhandeln ist das
nicht ein bisschen ungewöhnliches
Vorgehen auf diese Art und Weise einen
neuen Deal aushandeln zu wollen
guten Abend ich hoffe man kann mich
jetzt gut hören
tatsächlich in der Tat das klingt sehr
ungewöhnlich aber Herr prägogen ist ein
Chef einer Söldnergruppe und bereits im
Mittelalter schon im Mittelalter war es
unter Söldner normal die Deals neu zu
verhandeln insbesondere in Zeiten des
Krieges da sind die Chancen besser
genau das war das Ziel von pregorian er
war in einer schwierigen Situation im
Gefängnis nicht wie das russische
militäre Ministerium mit dem umgegangen
ist und deswegen wollte er neue
verhandeln
es ist allerdings schwer vorstellbar
dass pregorien das alles alleine geplant
hat es gibt hier z.B dieses Foto vom
Wochenende das können wir uns vielleicht
kurz anschauen in Roßdorf am Dorn mit
dem stellvertretenden
Verteidigungsminister und dem Vize Chef
des Militär Geheimdienstes dieses Bild
was sagt uns das haben diese beiden
Männer sich hinter ihnen gestellt
ja das sind tatsächlich sehr Interesse
interessante Bilder und Videos so wie
sie sich unterhalten und das ist auch
sehr interessant dass diese zwei
Menschen entschieden haben in rußdorf am
Dorn zu bleiben als die wagnergruppe
einmarschiert ist in Rosdorf Andron
faktisch waren sie Geiseln von Herrn
pregorian und das zeigt uns sehr viel
wir sehen wie ich ja Alexa hier lächelt
der Vize-Chef des Militär Geheimdienstes
als pregorian in fragt ob gerade
der wagnergruppe ausgeliefert werden
können und dieses Lächeln zeigt dass
etwas ganz schief läuft im russischen
Verteidigungsministerium wenn der
Vizechef solche Witze macht und über
solche Vorschläge und Angebote lächelt
sie sagen das werden quasi Geiseln
gewesen diese Gesprächsatmosphäre wird
sehr entspannt also wie Geiseln wirken
die nicht eher wie wie Verbündete
ich kann sagen der stellvertretender
Verteidigungsminister
er war gar nicht entspannt er war sehr
nervös kann sein dass er sich an die
Erfahrungen von in rocherten von der
russischen Teile Republik erinnert hat
das ist eine Heimat und da gab es eine
gleiche Geschichte vor 20 Jahren als die
titanischen Rebellen für zwei Tage
einmarschiert sind und das Territorium
der ganzen Teil Republik kontrollierten
das war einer der größten Krisen in der
Russischen Föderation 20 Jahre später
ist sowas in Rosdorf am Dorn passiert
andererseits kann ich Ihnen zuständig ja
Alexa der Vize-Chef des Militär
Geheimdienstes sah sehr entspannt aus
dass es einer sehr interessante Tatsache
das können wir noch gar nicht begreifen
als Schlussfolgerung kann man sagen der
Militär Geheimdienst das heißt dass es
eine Institution die unmittelbar im
Krieg gegen die Ukraine teilnimmt und
Aufklärung an der Front macht der fragt
ob die Autorität von seinem
Verteidigungsminister noch was hältst es
gibt ExpertInnen Experten die sagen
hätte diesen Aufstand niemals ohne
einflussreiche Unterstützer gewagt gibt
es die und wenn ja wer sind die
gibt es verschiedene Meinungen und
momentan beim russischen Militär was
hält man von tribogen da gibt es
verschiedene Ansichten viele mögen genau
das was er sagt dass er kritisiert
traditionellerweise gibt es eine sehr
skeptische Haltung zu den fortgesetzten
bei der russischen Armee die sogenannten
hohen Tiere die Generale haben keine
große Autorität das kann man ganz genau
von vollguss sagen vom
Verteidigungsminister erst ja kein
Militär von seiner Laufbahn gerade
jemand ist auch nicht sehr populär das
heißt dass die Worte von pregorian sehr
positiv von den russischen Offizieren
aufgenommen wurden ja andererseits die
Wagner Sollner sind dann in Bewegung
gekommen Richtung Moskau und dazu es ist
dazu gekommen dass mehrere Hubschrauber
solange gebracht wurden viele Piloten
starben und dann gab es auch Kritik
seitens der Armee schauen wir noch mal
auf diesen vergangenen Samstag dann die
wagnerkämpfer ja praktisch ungehindert
dieses russische militär-hauptquartier
in Roßdorf am donnern unter ihre in
Kontrolle gebracht warum gab es da
praktisch keine Gegenwehr
es gab tatsächlich keine Gegenwehr aber
nicht weil es ein Kollaps bei der
russischen Armee gab das möchte ich
betonen die russische Armee die
russischen Truppen haben den Krieg gegen
die Ukraine fortgesetzt es gab Gefechte
gegen die Ukraine als die wagnergruppe
bereits in Roßdorf am dorn war und das
ist tatsächlich sehr interessant denn
das ist genau der Kommando Punkt für den
russischen Krieg in der Ukraine aber die
Kapazität der russischen Armee blieper
halten das heißt die russische Armee und
die Militär Geheimdienste wussten nur
nicht was sie mit der Tribute nicht
Herausforderung warum
ist kein sogenannter System Mann oder
System Mensch nicht desto Trotz hat er
einen direkten gesprächskanal zu Putin
deswegen glaube ich dass Jeff oder
Alexei und andere generelle haben sich
selbst die Frage gestellt
was passiert
wenn privosin und Putin diese zwei
Petersburger sich wieder vertragen einen
neuen Deal verhandeln wer wird dann als
Schuldiger betrachtet und genau dieser
Gedanke hatten alle russischen Militärs
und Geheimdienstes deswegen wollten sie
einfach erstmal abwarten das heißt
zusammenfassend haben die sich einfach
nicht getraut sich in den Weg zu stellen
weil sie nicht wussten an welcher Seite
Putin entstehen würde
und sie hatten recht denn wie wir sehen
es gibt diesen neuen Deal und der
Verräter von gestern ganz ruhig nach
Minsk geflogen ist
ohne Hindernisse seine Söldner sind
weiterhin auf freiem Fuß und seine
Zentren sind immer noch offen und werben
nur Söllner an
es gibt eine Frage hier im Chat von
foodie auf Youtube er fragt er muss sein
jetzt insgeheim mit Konsequenzen von
Putin oder vom KGB rechnen
kann
natürlich denken wir jetzt alle an die
vielen Beispiele von Vergiftungen von
Mord an mehreren Menschen die Menschen
die als Feinde Putins gehalten ich
möchte nicht dass du trotz betonen dass
ich das Gefühl habe dass diese
Verbindung zwischen Puten und immer noch
gibt Putin glaubt wohl noch dass er noch
prägurken wird
seiner Gruppe
genau deswegen glaube ich wurde das
Strafverfahren die Ermittlung gegen
pregorian eingestellt das heißt seine
Firmen können weiterhin in Russland
tätig sein alle
finanziellen Mitteln kann er weiterhin
bekommen da gibt es keine Probleme ich
glaube Putin braucht die Dienste von
pregorian in Afrika im Nahen Osten und
auch im Internet und jetzt schauen wir
noch mal auf die Rolle des
belarussischen Präsidenten Lukaschenko
der von sich selbst behauptet er habe in
diesem Konflikt vermittelt welche Rolle
spielt er
ich glaube das ist eine sehr komplexe
und unangenehme Frage ausgerechnet für
den Präsidenten Putin 20 Jahre lang
erzählte Putin seinem Volk den Russen
dass es sehr wichtig wäre die nationale
Souveränität zu bewahren das war der
Vorwand um die repressalen Repressionen
anzufangen gegen die Opposition gegen
die Journalisten wie ich oder auch gegen
die nicht Regierungsorganisationen so
dass es keine Einmischung in die inneren
Angelegenheiten Russland gibt in die
innere Politik nun haben wir die
folgende Situation er hat ein Konflikt
mit seinem Diener mit seinem Gastronomen
mit seinem Koch und ausgerechnet in
dieser Situation
lädt er seinen sozusagen kleinen
Partnern ein zu helfen Lukaschenko und
er hatte Putin hatte nie Respekt vor
Lukaschenko in dieser Situation
erodierte die Idee der nationalen
Souveränität das ist psychologisch und
faktisch eine sehr schwierige Situation
für Putin und was passiert denn jetzt im
Kreml oder vielleicht kommen wir zur
zentralen Frage unseres Streams muss
Putin jetzt um sein politisches
Überleben kämpfen
gute Frage
es ist nur so dass es für uns sehr
schwierig das zu verstehen Putin im
Jahre 23
kann man nicht vergleichen mit Putin mit
einem Putin von früher ich habe ja schon
dieses Beispiel genannt tschetschenische
Rebellen in der russischen Teil der
Republiken vor 20 Jahren damals gab es
mehrere Entlassungen von Geheimdienstler
denn man hat diese Region unter Krise
damals gestellt die heutige Krise ist
viel größer war nicht nur im Rüstung von
Dorn er war schon fast vor Moskau im
Gebiet Moskau 100 km von Moskau
und anstatt Folgen zu ziehen will Puten
jetzt seine Militärs nicht entlassen
sondern
will sie auszeichnen und das so gibt es
keine Erklärung ich schau noch mal im
Chat hier gibt es noch einige Fragen
Chris fragt z.B hat Putin in erster
Linie die Kontrolle über den FSB oder
stützt sich seine Macht auf mehr Säulen
Inlandsgeheimdienst ist natürlich der
Hauptdienst aber darüber hinaus gibt es
zum Beispiel die nationale geachtet es
gibt auch
Kartierung Kämpfer siehe wurden zum zum
Witz sehe haben so viel Zeit gebraucht
um nach Roßdorf zu kommen das erst am
Abend angekommen waren als alles schon
zu Ende war mit Absicht kann man sagen
aber natürlich
der Geheimdienst FFB spielte sich eine
zentrale Rolle denn sie sagten der
Wagner dann Söldner dass sie priorischen
verhaften Solingen das ist jetzt sehr
komisch und sehr ungewöhnlich denn wer
kann jemanden in Russland verhaften die
Polizei der Geheimdienst aber natürlich
nicht die Söldner man kann
schlussfolgern die FSB Mitarbeiter
hatten einfach Angst selbst Prägungen zu
verhaften
und vielleicht noch eine letzte Frage
aus dem Chat ähm wenn schon die
wagner-söldner besser wieder abdrehen
wer sollte Putin denn jetzt noch
gefährlich werden ist das nicht eine
positive Erkenntnis für Putin
schwierige Frage
außer wagnergruppe gibt es ja noch die
KG Ruf Gruppe und Gruppe sie stehen fast
nicht unter der Controller der
russischen Armee obwohl sie vorher ein
Teil der nationalen Garde sind
faktisch haben sie nur falsch Chef und
Befehlshaber was passiert mit dem
russischen Geheimdienst wenn die KDF
Truppe Richtung einer russische Stadt
sich ausbrechen das versteht man nicht
denn gerade darauf hat seine persönliche
Beziehung zu Putin man kann sagen das
ist eine tickende
Russland haben diese Lehre jetzt nur
gelernt und gesehen und zwar wenn es ein
Konflikt innerhalb der putinalität gibt
soll man raushalten
Herr Soldaten ich danke Ihnen sehr für
das Gespräch und ihre Einschätzung
tschüss
vielen Dank
ja soweit die Einschätzung des
russischen Geheimdienst Experten und
investigativ Journalisten lass uns jetzt
in die Ukraine schauen da ist mein
Kollege daran Hassan Sade aktuell ist er
in SAP
hallo also daraus scheint bestätigt
wagnerführer brigoschin ist in Belarus
seine Kämpfer können dorthin ins Exil
gehen wenn Sie wollen ist das eine
Situation auf die sich das ukrainische
Militär einstellt das von dort aus
Angriffe kommen könnten
ja ich denke sie haben sich schon immer
mit der Gefahr befasst dass aus Belarus
sein erneuter Angriff drohen könnte bzw
erneut ist nicht ganz richtig der
Angriffe aus dem Norden ähm russische
Truppen wenn jetzt eine Vielzahl der
Wagner Soldaten sich dort aufhalten
sollten und versammeln sollen noch ist
ja unbekannt wie viele dort überhaupt
hingegangen sind und das Angebot
wahrnehmen können es ist ja auch es gibt
ja auch das Angebot an diese Soldaten
dass sie sich in die russische Armee so
integrieren dann wäre das natürlich eine
große Gefahr doch die Ukraine hat lange
Verteidigungslinien in den letzten
Monaten angelegt die
Grenzsoldaten überwachen den
belarussischen Raum sehr genau und der
Presse Sprecher der Grenzsoldaten in der
Ukraine hat heute ganz klar gesagt dass
sie keine Beobachtung haben von z.B
Bautätigkeiten für größere Kasernen in
denen sich eine große Menge sagen wir
mal von mehreren tausend Wagner Soldaten
dann auch aufhalten könnten
Kiew sagt ja dass es Fortschritte gibt
bei der Gegenoffensive hat das
ukrainische Militär in irgendeiner Art
und Weise von der Situation am
Wochenende in Russland profitiert
ja das kann man also wenn man sie in
zeitlichen Zusammenhang setzt dann kann
man davon ausgehen es gab mehrere
gebietsgebirge Gewinne zum Beispiel in
bachmut an den Flanken und es wäre
natürlich auch innenpolitisch sehr
brisant für Russland die Wagner Truppen
waren ja
ausschlaggebend das bachmodell erobert
werden konnte und wenn nach ihrem Abzug
die Stadt dann irgendwann wieder fallen
würde oder eingekreist werden kann durch
die ukrainische Armee dann wäre das ein
Problem es gab aber auch in der Südfront
das hat selenski ja noch mal betont an
allen Frontabschnitten Erfolge und das
bemerkenswerteste war dass ähm bekannt
wurde dass bei Person über den Fluss nie
pro
ukrainische Soldaten auf der anderen
Seite eine Art Brückenkopf im Aufbau
haben und das wäre strategisch schon von
besonderer Bedeutung denn von Herzen hat
man zum einen den Landzugang zur Krim
den man angehen könnte und zum sondern
könnte man die stark befestigten
Verteidigungslinien der Russen nördlich
von Melitopol von einer zweiten
Frontseite her angreifen das wäre eine
Situation die militärisch glaube ich
eine große Herausforderung für die
russische Armee in diesem Gebiet
darstellt zumal die andere krimbrücke
vor vier Tagen sehr stark beschädigt
wurde wurde so dass man davon ausgehen
kann dass von dort schweres Material und
Munition für die Versorgung der
Verteidigungslinie im Süden nicht mehr
so gebracht werden kann lass uns in die
russisch besetzten Gebiete schauen wie
ist die Situation dort aktuell
es ist schwierig von dort Informationen
zu bekommen
freies Arbeiten gibt es dort nicht es
wurde aber bekannt dass am Samstag als
dem Tag an dem die Wagner Truppen gehen
Moskau marschiert sind zwei 16-Jährige
erschossen wurden das waren Aktivisten
die schon sehr lange immer mit
ukrainischen Fahnen durch ihre
stadtweltjans gelaufen sind sie waren
auch Journalisten bekannt und das zeigt
natürlich dass da eine Art grausame
Nervosität auf der russischen Seite
entstanden ist während dieser sich
nennen es jetzt einfach mal diesen
Wagner Marsch und die Situation dürfte
sehr angespannt sein und ähm die Ukraine
wird natürlich versuchen daraus Vorteile
auch an der Front zu ziehen damit ich
mir relativ sicher gleichzeitig und ähm
eben kam gerade die Meldung dass in
kremators kein Raketeneinschlag
stattfand das ähm die ersten Bilder die
ich kurz sehen konnte sehen wirklich
furchtbarlich aus dieser Beschuss wird
wahrscheinlich
weitergehen auf die ukrainischen Städte
denn sie bindet die Luftabwehr der
Ukraine und diese kann da nicht an die
Front verlegt werden was natürlich
vorrückende Panzer und Bodentruppe enorm
stärken würde
vielen Dank Sarah du wirst uns weiter
auf dem laufenden halten in unseren
Kanälen und in unseren Sendungen mach's
gut alles Gute tschüss
und damit gehen wir direkt weiter zu
Severin Playa vom Bundeswehr Think Tank
gids mit ihm wollen wir über die
Auswirkungen des wagneraufstands
sprechen guten Abend guten Abend
vielleicht zunächst die Frage alle
schauen jetzt auf wagner-chef brigochin
und seine Leute wie groß ist der
Einfluss und das Wirken dieser Truppe
insbesondere jetzt im Ukraine kriegen
ich glaube das muss man zuallererst
differenzierter betrachten denn wenn es
die Gruppe Wagner also wenn Sie eines
geschafft haben dann ist es ein
narrativ um sich herumzuschaffen in wir
im Westen auch zu gerne übernehmen und
man muss sich immer vor Augen führen wie
viele Truppenteile wirklich der Gruppe
Wagner in erster Linie zugeordnet werden
können das heißt man muss unterscheiden
zwischen Wehrpflichtigen oder auch
Gefangenen niedergruppe Wagner zugeteilt
worden sind oder diese aus den
Gefängnissen rekrutiert haben zum einen
und dann natürlich auch die ähm zeig mir
die Kerngruppe der Gruppe Wagner das
sind dann die Elite Soldaten oder halt
auch die Spezialkräfte
wenn man sich Bach Mut anguckt ist es
Bild ein bisschen muss man das anders
betrachten wenn die
Unterstützungsleistungen insbesondere
der russischen föderationstruppen waren
ja schon immens also was Artillerie
anging was Luftschläge angehen und
natürlich auch was generell auch die
munitionsleistung angeht
deswegen ist die Frage auch noch mal zu
stellen inwieweit die Gruppe Wagner denn
auch wirklich eigenständig agiert hat
und da sind ein paar Fragenzeichen
es gibt hier eine Frage aus dem Chat von
Basti er fragt wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass das alles ein Vorwand war eine List
damit brigochian nach Belarus kommt dort
eine Einheit aufbaut und von dort aus
Kiew angegriffen werden soll
ist eine naheliegende Frage hat aber ein
paar praktische Umsetzungsprobleme denn
wir wissen nicht wie viele der Söldner
Truppen tatsächlich nach Belarus
verlegen und auch Weißrussland und
insbesondere Lukaschenko haben kein
Interesse daran in diesem Konflikt mit
reingezogen zu werden denn zu Beginn des
Krieges gab es ja bereits die Situation
wo sie sich Präsident Wladimir Putin
erhofft hatte das weiß russische Truppen
mit einmarschieren er hat aber aufgrund
der innenpolitischen Spannungen in der
letzten Jahre massive Probleme anders
Macht zu bleiben und somit wird er kein
Interesse daran haben in den Konflikt in
einer weiteren Kriegspartei mit
hineingezogen zu werden also es liegt
eher nahe dass rigorien dort tatsächlich
wenn überhaupt die Truppen trainiert
oder eine Alternative
sollte eine Truppe aufbaut
es gibt ja das Angebot dass sie Wagner
sondern nach belausus eben gehen können
das haben wir ja gehört Übersicht dem
russischen Militär anschließen ist das
denn überhaupt eine Alternative für
diese Männer
also zu allererst muss man festhalten
die Gruppe Wagner ist nicht die einzige
söldnerformation an der Front sie ist
die bekannteste und das schließt den
Kreis wieder zu dem was ich anfangs
gesagt hatte es gibt diesen narrativ
rund um die Gruppe Wagner es gibt aber
in der Russischen Föderation mehrere
dieser Formationen unter anderem hat
auch verteilungsminister scheuburg zum
Beispiel die Gruppe Patriot die Gruppe
Patriot ist ähnlich stark wie die Gruppe
Wagner ist aber weniger bekannt
und auch der Wechsel von den
Spezialkräften und von den nennen wir
sie mal Söldner zwischen der Gruppe
Patriot zum Beispiel zu Gruppe Wagner
oder auch zu anderen Formationen der
kann fließend sein denn diese Leute
unterschreiben Verträge von zwei Monaten
bis sechs Monaten und werden dort
überdurchschnittlich gut bezahlt jetzt
ist es so natürlich dass seit das ab dem
1 Juli all diese Verbände ja in die
russische
normale Formation mit integriert werden
sollen die Frage die sie raus wirklich
ergibt ist
wo und wie werden diese Leute weiter
bezahlt den aktuell werden Sie über den
separaten Haushalt oder direkt von
diesen Personen bezahlt
insbesondere die Gruppe Patriot von
verdachtsminister scheuburg wird da auch
einige Fragen dazu beantworten haben was
noch heute auch eben auch endlich
bestätigt bekommen hat ich meine wir
haben es eigentlich schon längere Zeit
gewusst aber der russische Staat hat zum
Beispiel die Gruppe Wagen den ersten
Linie finanziert
dazu gibt es auch eine Frage von Achim
was hat das denn für Auswirkungen für
Putin wenn er jetzt offen zugibt die
Wagner Truppen finanziert zu haben die
ja in diversen Konflikten weltweit in
der Vergangenheit in Erscheinung
getreten sind
also in erster Linie zeigt es auf dass
Vladimir Putin alarmiert ist darüber
dass die Grauzonen Taktik die er
gefahren hatte eben dieses dass man die
Soldaten nicht eindeutig zuordnen konnte
der Russischen Föderation nicht mehr
funktioniert und somit hat er einen
macht Vakuum das erschließen möchte er
möchte dass die Staatlichkeit wieder
zentrale ist das heißt alle Gewalt geht
direkt von ihm aus und somit werden die
Streitkräfte wieder gestärkt es ist
deswegen auch nicht überraschend dass
jetzt zum Beispiel heute auch schon der
russische Außenminister in einer
längeren Ansprache davon sprach dass zum
Beispiel die Zentralafrikanische
Republik und auch die Gruppe Wagner im
Sudan in die russischen Streitkräfte mit
hineingezogen werden somit werden wir
wahrscheinlich eher davon eher mehr
davon sehen dass die Russische
Föderation tatsächlich Verantwortung und
auch das Label übernimmt der Einsätze
die derzeit in Afrika stattfinden
okay und damit haben Sie auch schon
dankenswerterweise zwei Fragen
beantwortet nämlich ob es Wagner
außerhalb Russland wie früher in Syrien
und Afrika noch gibt und ähm
parasa hatte noch gefragt interessant
wäre auch was mit Wagner wird den
anderen Ländern aktiv sind zum Beispiel
Mali oder so dann wunderbar es gibt noch
eine andere Frage von cremeschnitzel was
sagen eigentlich die seltener von Wagner
dazu dass alles abgeblasen hat und
selber einen Deal ausgehandelt hat ohne
die sollten dazu beachten wollen die
überhaupt noch Belarus
da muss man sich eben genau auch die
Formulierungen anschauen die dort
benutzt worden sind das heißt sie haben
hier die Wahl sich integrieren zu lassen
und es gibt ja weit andere Formationen
die an ähnliches Schicksal haben zum
Beispiel die Leute von kadirov müssen ja
auch bald meine Wahl treffen wenn man
möchte eben diese diesen Wildwuchs ein
hegen der Stadt gefunden hatte über die
letzten Jahrzehnte da was politisch
gewollt in einem großen Krieg ist es
halt eher ja nicht gerade sehr produktiv
wenn man viele unabhängige kriegs aber
oder Kriegsherren hat die dort
mitmischen das ist ja gerade die
Grundproblematik um die Schlacht bei
bachmut zum Beispiel gewesen
deswegen uns einfach zu beantworten wir
wissen nicht wie sich die sollten da
weiter verhalten denn wir wissen auch
gar nicht was ihr Status ist viele
dieser Soldaten zum Beispiel auch in der
Gruppe Patriot oder auch in der Gruppe
Wagner sind teilweise aktive
gau-soldaten oder spätnuts das heißt ich
Spezialkräfte der Russischen Föderation
inwieweit das geht kann man momentan
nicht beurteilen
wir haben eingangs die Bilder gezeigt
von pregorian am Wochenende in Roßdorf
am Dorn gemeinsam mit dem
stellvertretenden
Verteidigungsminister und dem Vize-Chef
des Militärgeheimdienstes hier sehen wir
sie noch mal
wie ist dieses Zusammenwirken diese
diese Unterstützung für projen und es
scheint kompliziert zu sein in Russland
das Zusammenwirken von Militär und
privaten Firmen vielleicht können Sie
das erklären
man muss dann auch noch mal einen
Schritt zurückgehen denn im Jahr 2012
und auch in den Jahren davor gab es
mehrere militäre Formen die die
wesentlichen Strukturelemente der
Russischen Föderation komplett ersetzt
haben also ich damit meine der
Verteidigungsminister scheuburg zum
Beispiel wurde einige seiner seiner
Machtfülle beraubt und dafür diese dem
Garagen immer noch gegeben deswegen gab
es ja auch ähm eine sozusagen
militärisierung der Außenpolitik
gewissen Aspekten
des Weiteren wenn man sich die das Bild
eben anschaut dass da im Rost auf Odon
gezeichnet worden ist mit den beiden
Herren neben brigochien ist es
aufschlussreich also ich schließe mich
da auch nicht ganz der Einschätzung
meines Vorredners an denn die beiden
Herren sind nicht
umsonst gewählt worden einer davon yes
ist insbesondere eben auch dafür bekannt
dass er sehr nationalistisch agiert das
heißt alle die dort sitzen haben einen
besonderen
Drang oder auch ein besonderes ja
Verständnis wie oder wohin die Russische
Föderation gehen soll
insbesondere auch ist die Historie der
beiden Herren auch sehr interessant also
zum Beispiel ist der sogenannte Held von
Pristina und Pristina weil eben damals
die Situation dass 200 russische
Fallschirmjäger ohne Unterstützung den
Flughafen und richtete genommen hat und
somit die Russische Föderation all
wieder als ernsthaften
Partner für Verhandlungen über die
Zukunft des Kosovos überhaupt zugelassen
hat also man spricht davon zwei Leuten
die tatsächlich ein Interesse daran
haben dass die Russische Föderation
gestärkt wird des Weiteren ist auch der
stellvertretende gau-chef dort Anwesen
gewesen das ist deswegen interessant
weil die Gruppe Wagner eigentlich auf
einen Initiative der Gho zurückgeht von
2010 diese hat neben die Absicht es
immer mehr zu verschleiern wo russische
Soldaten im Einsatz sind es hat ja auch
den anderen Vorteil dass wenn ich
Verluste habe diese nicht zu Hause
anzeigen muss also deswegen halte ich
dieses Bildmaterial immer noch für sehr
sehr spannend ich würde aber momentan
davor warnen sich nur auf diese drei
Leute zu fokussieren sondern eben auch
zu gucken wie die Aufarbeitung oder die
Abwicklung der Gruppe Wagner jetzt
abläuft denn heute wurde ja angekündigt
dass die Concorde Gruppe also die
Holding der Gruppe Wagner also die
Gruppe Wagner hat ja ein großes
firmenkonstrukt die soll ja abgewickelt
werden aufgrund von Verstößen gegen das
russische Steuerrecht und da kann man
gespannt sein was da noch zu Tage kommt
möchte gerne wissen kann Putin es sich
überhaupt leistenbrigogin am Leben zu
lassen also der Politikwissenschaftler
Münkler hat ja heute im Interview gesagt
er geht davon aus dass der russische
Geheimdienst ihn über kurz oder lang
ermorden wird
man muss sagen dass die das Verhältnis
von brigoroshin zu Vladimir Putin ein
spezielles ist
genauso wie das Verhältnis von
Verteidigungsminister schulgo zu
Vladimir Putin und zumindest die Frage
glaube ich eher nicht dass er
verschwindet weil ich glaube das kann er
sich Jagd in den aktuellen Umständen gar
nicht leisten denn hat viele Bewunderer
geschaffen also wenn er eines mit der
Aktion von ähm vom Wochenende geschafft
hat dann ist es sein eigenes Überleben
zu sichern denn wenn ihm jetzt was
zustößt wird zum Amateure gemacht und er
hätte ab sofort auch wirklich größere
Probleme als nur ein hungriger deswegen
ist eigentlich das ähm es anzunehmen
dass es einfacher ist die Gruppe Wagner
indirekt abzuwickeln seine Verdienste
anzuerkennen aber ihnen sozusagen aus
dem politischen herauszuhalten und noch
eine Frage von Don Ben gibt es andere
Strömungen in Russland paramilitärische
die diesen Abstand nutzen könnten bzw
selbst einen versuchen könnten denn es
ist ja eine schwierige Situation für
Putin es gibt ja noch mehr Kämpfer an
der Seite der russischen Armee in der
Ukraine als nächstes könnt ihr zum
Beispiel jetzt RAM seinen kadura um die
Ecke kommen
also wir haben so ein kadiro halte ich
für ihr unwahrscheinlich denn er ist
wirklich einer der treuen von Wladimir
Putin aber was spannend ist ist das eben
aufgrund des Marsches auf Moskau von von
dem Herrn eine Situation geschaffen
wurden ist wo Teil Truppenteile der
regulären russischen Streitkräfte
übergelaufen sind und da wird es
interessant zu sehen wie mit denen
weiter verfahren wird wenn da waren auch
Elite Verbände dabei und auch teilweise
Teile der
nahbereichsflug Abwehr zum Beispiel und
somit ist es eben nicht nur die Gruppe
Wagner die diesen Aufstand gemacht hat
die Unterstützer davon kann man davon
ausgehen dass die also mal anders gesagt
die USA der us-geheimnis hat ja Wind von
dieser Aktion bekommen ungefähr vier
oder fünf Tage vorher aufgrund dessen
dass sie Oligarchen abgehört hatten das
heißt er muss auch Unterstützung aus der
OLGA hier haben und es muss ein breit
gefächertes Netzwerk in Russland geben
die daran Interesse daran hatten dass es
so durchgeführt worden ist was dir
genauen Interessen sind da kann man
jetzt nur mutmaßen das will ich in dem
Rahmen nicht machen aber es gibt
Bestrebungen insbesondere von
nationalistischen Gruppen dort ein
stärkeres und forcierteres Vorgehen der
russischen Föderationen eben zu
forcieren und kundag stellt sich die
Frage wie viel schwächer ist die Armee
Russlands jetzt ohne die Söldnergruppe
Wagner wird es jetzt bedeutend einfacher
in Anführungszeichen für die
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine oder macht
das nur wenig aus
also es wird kein signifikanten
Unterschied in diesem Maße machen wenn
man muss sich vor Augen für noch mal wie
viele Leute von wie vielen Leuten wir
wirklich tatsächlich sprechen und was
ich auch vorhin gerade auch ausgeführt
hatte viele der Söldner wechseln von
Gruppe zu Gruppe das wird sich natürlich
jetzt auch ändern und ich nehme jetzt
auch stark an dass viele der Leute eher
auf der russischen föderationsseite
unterschreiben werden als sie jetzt mit
Herrn dann in Nachweis Russland zu
wechseln
das nächste ist halt auch ähm momentan
war die Gruppe Wagner oder bis vor
kurzem war die Gruppe Wagen
hauptsächlich im Bach Mut eingesetzt
alle anderen Frontabschnitte waren mit
regulären russischen Soldaten oder eben
anderen
Sicherheitsfirmen belegt und sind auch
nach wie vor belegt das heißt wir haben
eigentlich keine Situation wo jetzt ein
direktes Vakuum kommt wo es aber
natürlich ein Unterschied macht ist dass
man jetzt Truppen wahrscheinlich von der
Front teilweise auch abziehen muss um
diese für die Sicherheit im eigenen Land
so garantieren
zum Schluss noch die Frage eine
Einschätzung was denken sie war das am
Wochenende der Auftakt wird Putin dieser
Krieg den er ja so unbedingt wollte
letztlich zu Fall bringen
ich glaube
da wir am Wochenende auch gesehen haben
wie oft alle überrascht sind von manchen
Entwicklungen kann man nichts
ausschließen aber man kann es jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie vorhersagen und das wäre
auch unseriös das an dieser Stelle zu
tun
man muss aber festhalten dass das
langsames Netzwerk Weg bröckelt ob das
aber heißt dass es ultimative Schwächung
seines Regimes ist das wage ich momentan
noch zu bezweifeln
wir werden es auf jeden Fall weiter
beobachten Herr Player ich danke Ihnen
sehr für das Gespräch und ihre
Einschätzung haben Sie noch einen
schönen Abend tschüss vielen Dank
schönen Abend
und ich danke natürlich auch euch für
eure vielen Fragen und Kommentare vielen
lieben Dank danke fürs zuschauen und bis
bald ZDF heute live tschüss
[Musik]